let's get reaction now from former
attorney general mike mew kz general
Mukasey judge Mukasey it's great to see
you you just heard from the congressman
I mean this is wild the Justice
Department said you've received all the
documents essentially you're entitled to
where are we tonight judge well I
haven't seen the subpoena and I haven't
seen the documents so I'm a little bit
in the dark about where we are but it's
not an impossible task to turn over
documents I think they want to do more
discussing between and among themselves
then posturing publicly well it looks
like it the documents Nunez requested
were about informants placed inside the
Trump campaign or who approached the
Trump campaign I think part of what he's
trying to determine when this
investigation really began because they
were saying that this investigation into
the Trump possible collusion began at
the end of July 2016 but indications are
that it began really in the spring of
2016 State Department very well involved
Christopher steel net dossier in and out
of the halls of Justice and in perhaps
the State Department so I think that's
what they're worried about that who was
really running this investigation and
who gave it the impetus judge from the
very beginning well you hit the nail on
the head that's what we really need to
know is when it started and how and to
the extent that there was I mean I'm
interested for example in knowing how
this informant who started out as a CIA
asset suddenly became an FBI informant
you know those two those two
organizations don't really play with
each other's toys and I don't understand
how that happened
who brought it about who paid him what
his what he was told about his
responsibilities in going into the Trump
campaign and when that happened that is
something that I think we ought to know
if there were any others obviously we
going to know that as well judge
something I just asked congressman
meadows about the failure of the
Inspector General to reveal who these
staff attorneys are at justice and again
it looks like one of them mr. Klein
Smith who's writing unbelievable text
messages that he was so depressed after
the election he was stressed and
depressed and basically saying the
resistance lives on he's in Valle
in at the heart of this investigation
along was struck and of course Moore's
but we're not revealing who these people
are why they're not undercover agents
obviously not and I think that even more
significant at least to me is not just
the statements about the resistance but
rather of a set of messages that passed
between Strock and his and his his
friend the night that Donald Trump got
the nomination where she wrote to him
this is unbelievable that Trump has
gotten the nomination his response was
yeah this increases the pressure to
terminate my II which was the the the
codename mid-year exam for the Clinton
investigation that's not just an
expression of opinion that is a
statement about how we ought to do our
jobs and that on my reading was not in
the IG report I don't recall seeing it
and that's something I think they what a
questions talk about when he testifies
and judge he was just walked out of the
DOJ last week apparently he just lost
his security clearance I mean that's
what Jeff session said well he just lost
his security clearance someone who is an
advocate a political advocate running to
critical investigations as a lead
investigator I mean I never worked at
DOJ I worked at you know White House and
transportation education but Supreme
Court but I don't worked at DOJ but if
that's the way business is done at the
DOJ these high levels we're big trouble
in this country big trouble
well it's it certainly doesn't inspire
confidence nor does this there was the
something that was reported in the IG
report namely that there were FBI agents
in contact with the press who were
getting free meals free tickets and
other and other perks and that there
were so many of them they couldn't tell
who had leaked information now that was
a that was an absolute jaw dropper the
notion that FBI agents were getting yeah
compensation essentially from reporters
and developing relationships with them
yeah how was it
that's that should have been that should
have been a firing offense judge thank
you